Yo c'est Cyrus,
et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode du Coup de Phil' .
Il y a à peu près un mois je vous ai sorti un épisode #AskCyrusNorth
où j'ai parlé des preuves de l'existence de Dieu
et j'en ai parlé comme si croire en Dieu, ça faisait appel à la raison.
Si ça fait appel à la raison, il faut absolument que je vous parle du Pari de Pascal.
Et ça c'est le Paris de Cyrus.
C'est vraiment nul...
Alors j'avais déjà parlé de notre ami Pascal dans le 3ème Coup de Phil' ,
mais là on va voir vraiment l'aspect religieux du personnage,
parce que Pascal il est très très croyant.
Et d'ailleurs il passe pas mal de temps avec des joueurs,
des joueurs de cartes, des joueurs de paris, des choses comme ça.
Ce qui l'aide pour ses travaux en probabilité
car c’est un grand mathématicien
Mais au-delà de ça il va faire un parallèle entre ces activités-là, donc le jeu
et le fait de croire en Dieu
En gros il va créer 2 propositions
qui sont le fait de croire en Dieu ou de ne pas croire en Dieu
et on va considérer qu'il n'y a pas d'autre choix
et que tous les individus de la planète
ils rentrent forcément dans l'une des 2 catégories
Pour chaque choix, croire en Dieu, ou non
il s'en suit des conséquences par rapport à l'existence réelle de Dieu
par exemple si je décide de croire en dieu,
je vais me couper de certaines choses pour ce Dieu
par contre si ce Dieu existe, à ma mort, j'aurais une récompense éternelle
du coup ça nous donne le tableau suivant:
on va poser ε comme étant le kiff
que peut apporter une vie sans obligation religieuse
ou la contrainte que peut infliger une vie religieuse.
Déjà soit on parie sur l'existence de Dieu,
soit on parie sur l'inexistence de Dieu.
Ensuite, soit Dieu existe, soit Dieu n'existe pas
Dans tous les cas, si vous pariez sur l'existence de Dieu
eh bien on va dire que votre vie religieuse
va vous donner certaines obligations ou contraintes
et du coup on va mettre - ε
dans toutes les cases.
À l'inverse si vous pariez sur l'inexistence de Dieu,
vous pouvez faire vraiment tout ce que vous voulez
et là on va mettre +ε.
Ensuite si Dieu n'existe pas il n'y a ni paradis ni enfer
et donc quoique vous croyiez,
après la mort vous retournez au néant
donc on va mettre 0.
Par contre si Dieu existe,
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué,
parce que soit vous avez cru en lui et dans ce cas là,
direction paradis mon gars, tu gagnes indéfiniment, + l'infini
soit il existe et vous avez pas cru en lui
et dans ce cas-là, direction l'enfer,
vous perdez indéfiniment, - l'infini
Alors on utilise ε parce que ε en mathématique
c'est pour des valeurs qui sont très faibles
donc on considère que le kiff ou la contrainte de la vie religieuse,
c'est rien du tout par rapport au reste.
Alors après, ce pari ça n'a de sens que si on se dit que
soit tu décides de croire en Dieu, soit tu décides de ne pas croire en Dieu.
Paradis.
Bonjour.
Excusez-moi je suis désolé en fait j'étais à une soirée orientale quand c'est arrivé.
J'me suis étouffé avec du houmous donc euh...
Monsieur il faut me remplir ce formulaire, vous remplissez ce formulaire et vous revenez au guichet.
Non non si si je l'ai vu mais c'est juste qu'en fait c'est ni l'un ni l'autre, je...
Comment ça c'est ni l'un ni l'autre?
Bah en fait j'étais agnostique quoi.
Pff vous me faites chier hein...
Faites un choix et assumez le, comme tout le monde !
Roger on fait quoi avec les agnostiques là, paradis ? Enfer ?
Il y a une salle spéciale pour ça.
Ah bon?
Ah bah vous avez de la chance en plus.
On se fait chier ici nan?
Grave/oui/Ca dépend/parfois oui, parfois non
Le truc c'est que si on reprend le pari de Pascal c'est logiquement plus intéressant de croire en Dieu.
Parce que si je crois en Dieu, soit je me goure et dans ce cas là j'ai - ε,
soit j'ai raison et j'ai + l'infini.
Alors que si je décide de pas croire en Dieu
Soit j'ai raison et j'ai +ε, soit j'ai tort et j'ai - l'infini.
Donc le pire si je crois en Dieu c'est - ε :
" Non Mélissa arrête d'insister, je ferai pas l'amour à toi et à toutes tes amies,
j'ai décidé de vivre une vie chaste. "
Et si je crois pas en Dieu,
C'est - l'infini :
"" Satan épargne-moi ! ""
Je crois que c'est mieux d'éviter le - l'infini,
je crois que c'est mieux de croire en Dieu en fait.
Sauf que bizarrement c'est pas aussi simple,
un mec qui n'est pas croyant tu ne peux pas le convaincre avec cet argument alors qu'a priori il est logique et mathématique.
Du coup Pascal il se rend compte que ce n'est pas avec la raison que tu peux croire en Dieu.
Et c'est d'ailleurs lui qui est l'auteur de la citation "le coeur à ses raisons que la raison ignore".
Et là tous ceux qui avaient un skyblog vont me demander le rapport.
Mais le rapport c'est que quand Pascal dit ça, le coeur c'est la foi,
la foi en Dieu.
Donc le coeur à ses raisons que la raison ignore,
ça veut dire que la foi et la raison sont deux choses séparées.
Et donc qu'il suffit pas d'un argument logique pour croire en Dieu.
Donc ça n'a rien à voir avec vos histoires d'amour.
Bonjour,
je viens vous voir parce que je viens de voir une vidéo de Cyrus North,
et en fait mon tatouage c'est pas vraiment ce que je voulais dire.
Ouais je sais j'ai fais une faute d'orthographe.
Ah bon ?
Après dans la lignée du pari de Pascal ou plutôt avant lui,
il y a le moins connu pari de Marc-Aurèle.
En gros lui c'est simple il dit : "vis une bonne vie".
Bonne dans le sens de bien au niveau des valeurs etc.
Donc soit il y a des dieux,
et s'il y a des dieux c'est qu'ils sont justes,
dans ce cas là ils vont te juger en fonction de tes valeurs, de la vie que t'as menée
et pas en fonction de tes croyances, ok ?
Soit il n'y a pas de dieux et dans ce cas là,
c'est pas grave t'auras vécu une bonne vie et tu resteras dans la mémoire de tes amis.
Soit il y a des dieux mais ils sont injustes et ils valent pas la peine d'être vénérés.
Voilà, c'est Marc Aurèle, c'est un stoïcien.
Alors évidemment le pari de Pascal ça ne marche que si tu considères que c'est parce que tu ne crois pas en Dieu que tu vas forcément en enfer,
et vice-versa.
D'ailleurs vous pouvez faire un pari sur ma chaîne, c'est très simple,
il suffit de s'abonner et moi je vous garantis le + l'infini.
Je vous envoie du love
et de la peace,
Voilà j'espère que la pari de Pascal c'est maintenant plus clair pour vous.
Ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est la démarche de Pascal derrière tout ça.
C'est-à-dire de montrer que la raison et la croyance c'est deux choses qui sont complètement séparées.
N'hésitez pas à voir ma dernière vidéo sur les 5 preuves de l'existence de Dieu qui est dans la description,
et de voir la dernière video sur Nietzsche et le christianisme notamment qui doit être par là.
N'hésitez pas à me rejoindre sur Facebook pour des news que ce soit relatif à mon actu ou à l'actu en général ça peut arriver,
sur Twitter pour tout ce que je mets pas sur Facebook,
il y a beaucoup de choses que je mets pas sur Facebook
et mon Snapchat mais là c'est un peu plus perso donc voilà,
ça me fait plaisir.
Ciao !